non c'è dubbio che negli ultimi mesi dei
nostri vite sono cambiate in modo in cui
viviamo in un modo in cui interagiamo in
modo in cui usiamo i trasporti
bene questo è un campanello d'allarme
dalla natura è un campanello d'allarme
che deve farci capire quanto il mondo di
fuori di sé interconnesso quanto la
natura interconnessa bene ora sappiamo
che le nostre vite dipendono dal pianeta
alfano oltre a questa pandemia però c'è
una crisi una crisi ben più grande
una crisi climatica la chiamiamo crisi
non cassolo cambiamento perché una crisi
indotta dall uomo
io sono alessandra milotta non sono né
un ambientalista e non finiamo
scienziato sono un ragazzo innamorato
della tecnologia
questa tecnologia mi ha portato a fare
viaggi lontani a lavorare per il mondo
della moda
uno di questi viaggi e mi ha portato in
asia a vedere una fabbrica una fabbrica
che produce abbigliamento che noi tutti
indossiamo ogni giorno bene l'impatto di
questa fabbrica sulle persone è stato
devastante se da un punto di vista
personale da un punto di vista
ambientale
durante questa durante questa visita
chiesi alla persona che mi stava
guidando quale sarebbe stato il colore
di tendenza dell'anno prossimo come noi
tutti facciamo nella moda ci interessa
saperlo
questa persona mi disse di andare a
vedere il colore del fiume perché questo
insinuava che avrebbero scaricato tutte
le materie del fiume e di questa frase
l'avevo già sentito una volta è il fiume
ci sono andato andrea vedere il fiume
per fortuna il fiume non era nel rosso e
nei blu ma aveva un odore pazzesco è un
colore tremendo quello fu la prima volta
in cui mi resi conto del mio impatto del
mio stile di vita di quello che compravo
quello che in compravo e quello che
indossavo aveva un impatto negativo
sull'ambiente e facevo parte di un
sistema complesso che uccideva
l'ambiente in cui viviamo il nostro
pianeta quello è stato il mio campanello
d'allarme quello è stato il mio la mia
sveglia
bene oggi arriviamo al 2020 e se
possiamo imparare qualcosa da questa o
possiamo imparare che durante questa
pandemia si è già ma insieme tutti per
il bene comune
possiamo appiattire la curva dei contagi
e lasciare tempo la scienza di trovare
un bacino di fare il suo corso
lo stesso momento devono affrontare la
crisi allo stesso modo
dovevamo entrare nazionali tutti quanti
fare tanti piccoli tante piccole azioni
che possono aiutare il nostro pianeta
perché è importante
io tornai da da quella da quel viaggio
in asia è deciso di lasciare il mio
lavoro di lasciare con l'ambiente e ho
creato un'app un'app che aiuta st
sensibilizzare le persone che le potesse
guidare verso uno stile di vita
sostenibile che potesse far vedere a noi
tutti l'impatto delle nostre azioni
dalle piccole cose che possiamo fare
quotidianamente dalle piccole micro
azioni con molta positività dopo il
primo lancio dopo i primi dieci giorni
abbiamo avuto ai 10 mila iscritti le
persone si sono lasciate guidare e sono
entrati in azione a fare tutte queste
piccole infrazioni che sono importanti e
nei primi dieci giorni abbiamo
registrato un risparmio di 35 tonnellate
di co2 anche enorme equivalgono al
consumo annuale di 10 persone molto
grande cosa ci fa capire questo ci fa
capire che le persone hanno voglia di
fare qualcosa hanno voglia di mettersi
in gioco amico di riparazioni hanno
voglia di imparare ma non sanno dove
iniziare e si sentono soprattutto in
dovere di fare qualcosa è perché non lo
fanno non lo fanno perché le
informazioni che li passiamo strano a
volte complesse quando parliamo di
sostenibilità sono report con con numeri
che neanche io capivo
dobbiamo spiegare loro dobbiamo guidare
le persone a vivere questo terribilmente
tramite una lista di azioni
parliamo molte volte gli scenari
apocalittici invece di concentrarsi
sulle piccole cose che possiamo fare
quotidianamente nella nostra vita e
soprattutto la vita una vita sostenibile
sembra quasi una vita di una vita di
rinuncia quando una rinunciando
fatto bene come possiamo contrastare
questa crisi
io partire dalla consapevolezza dalla
consapevolezza che dobbiamo cambiare i
nostri comportamenti per uscire da
questa crisi dobbiamo fare tante piccole
migrazioni e coinvolgere più persone
possibili dobbiamo utilizzare gli
strumenti che abbiamo oggi e comunicare
i messaggi semplici empatici
consapevolezza anche nel sapere che
ognuno di noi ha un potere enorme
facciamo centinaia di scelte ogni giorno
compriamo prodotti utilizziamo servizi
votiamo e questo può aiutare a cambiare
le persone attorno a noi può spingere le
aziende a cambiare e forse anche le
istituzioni bene doveva utilizzare
secondo me la tecnologia involve quindi
portare più persone a bordo in questo
trasformi questa trasformazione in
questo cambiamento insegnare alle
persone e coinvolgerle coinvolgere verso
uno stile di vita sostenibile creare una
cittadinanza attiva con uno scopo ultimo
ben preciso quello di creare una cultura
della sostenibilità grazie